hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
classification and routine environmental
monitoring for gnp
clean rooms i am michelle ashton of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth
and brought to you by beckman culture
life sciences
to learn more please visit
www.beckman.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want
during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation
is educational ms offers continuing
education credit
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker tony
harrison senior marketing manager
at beckman coulter life sciences for a
complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
tony you may now begin your presentation
welcome
thank you thank you very much for that
introduction
hello and welcome everyone to this short
webinar today
on clean room monitoring and
classification
specifically for the gmp environment my
name is tony harrison
and i'm a senior manager for beckmann
coulter
i was also the uk expert to the iso
working group responsible for writing
the 2015 edition
of the iso standard for clean rooms iso
1464-1
so i wanted to share this quote with you
today
because sometimes clean room routine
environmental monitoring programs
can seem very burdensome and very manual
and the sheer volume of manual sampling
leading to a high volume of data to be
managed
these sheer volumes of data can be
confusing
and can lead to a lack of clarity
sometimes unfortunately resulting in
data
integrity errors
so in today's short webinar i will cover
the gmp requirements for clean room
monitoring
and the requirements for classification
and explain the difference
i will also outline why routine
monitoring presents such a challenge to
data integrity
and finally i'll give you some brief
highlights on the new clarity software
for routine monitoring
and how it can automate these programs
and help reduce
data errors
so first let's take a look at the rule
governing gmp clean room contamination
control
clean room contamination control for
sterile gmp manufacturing
is defined in the european gmp and the
north american
cgmp documents and both these gmp
documents reference the iso standard
i mentioned iso 14644-1
for the methodology methodology sorry
for clean room classification
so let's take a look at the gmp
regulations controlling the
contamination levels in these clean
rooms
this is the current table for for air
particle contamination levels
in the european gmp annex one and it's
also used in the guide for sterile
manufacturing from the world health
organization
you can see there are four grades of
clean room defined from the cleanest
grade a
through the dirtiest grade d
and you can also see that the european
version of gmp
calls for two particle sizes to be
measured 0.5 microns
and 5 microns now this is the same the
world over because the world health
organization uses the same
standard as well the only exception to
this is the north american cgmp
which currently only calls for 0.5
micron particles to be measured
and reported now all particle counts
are reported in particles per cubic
meter
and this in itself can present an area
of potential error for our
users because in order to reduce the
amount of time
taken in routine environmental
monitoring programs each day
the sample taken at each location is
typically reduced to just
one minute samples now with a particle
counter that captures one cubic foot
of air per minute it means that the
sample volume is just one cubic foot
because it's one minute sampling
now there are approximately 35.2 cubic
feet
in one cubic meter of air so the user
must multiply the count results by 35.2
to get the counts per meter now
most particle counters can be programmed
to automatically
make this calculation for the user but
it's another configuration step to
remember to make
to ensure the results are reported
correctly according to gmp
now people are the biggest source of
contamination in the clean room
environment
so workers in clean rooms have to pass
through several different clean rooms to
enter the production suite
where the aseptic fill takes place
each area is separated by an airlock to
minimize the
flow of air from the dirty outer rooms
into the clean production areas
particle counters have to be sanitized
as they pass from one grade of clean
room to another
and this is typically done by spraying
them with an industrial alcohol spray
called ipa
the dirtiest room is the grade d and
staff are required to change
out of their outdoor clothes here and
into clean room clothes
they then pass through into the grade c
preparation area where equipment used in
production
is prepared finally they will be
required to change their clothes again
as they pass into the production area
itself generally the grade a production
filling area is protected by a barrier
system
an isolator or a restrictive access
barrier system or wraps
and this prevents the workers from
entering into the aseptic core
and so around this this restricted
access barrier can be grade c
however if there is no physical barrier
into the filling zone
then the background around the grade a
must be grade b
now the north american fda cgmp document
differs to the european and the world
health organization guidance
in that it only mentions one particle
size the 0.5 micron particle
now if you remember the european version
talks about 0.5 micron and 5 micron
particles so it's quite different
however anybody based in manufacturing
in north america and wanting
to export their products and sell them
outside of north america
will have to count particles of both 0.5
and 5 microns
as they must in fact be in compliance
with the standards of the country to
which they want to export to
now we're all very aware at this time
and the the industry is in the middle of
a search for a cure for covid19
and of course that's the very disease
that's keeping its all at home
and for forcing us to have virtual
webinars like this one
now vaccine manufacturing plants are a
rather unique
subset of biopharma production in that
the production of a vaccine is usually
done by cultivating high concentrations
of the disease-causing pathogen in
bioreactors that optimize to support
microbial growth
this gives the manufacturer additional
challenges over and above the other
manufacturers of injectable
sterile drugs small molecule drugs that
is
because extra care must be taken to
avoid contaminating bacteria from the
production staff
from getting into the bioreactors and at
the same time
great care must be taken not to allow
any of the pathogen itself
from the cross-contaminating other
products manufactured in the same
facility
hence in vaccine production lines the
staff and the equipment working on them
are usually kept separated to prevent
cross contamination
now this means that they cannot move
particle counters from one clean room to
the next
because the particle counter could cross
contaminate the second room
so these challenges are so well known
that the world health organization
have a dedicated guidance specifically
for environmental monitoring of clean
rooms
in vaccine manufacturing facilities
now as i mentioned earlier both the
european gmp and the north american cgmp
documents
tell the reader to refer to the
classification procedures laid down in
iso
1464 when they are classifying their
clean room
now the iso standard is not a gmp
document
and it's actually really designed to
give guidance rather than mandate
but the fact that it is referenced by
the gmps gives it the
same status as the gmp document for
those manufacturers regulated by gmp
now this standard has a wide range of
clean room classes as you can see from
one to nine
and also covers a wide range of particle
sizes from 0.1 micron to 5 microns
and you can see in the middle of the
chart there the number of particles per
cubic meter
for each class which is allowed
now the idea is from the iso standard
that the user must decide
what particle sizes they're interested
in and how clean the clean room must be
for their process and then they choose a
subset
of the clean room class and particle
size from the iso table
now gmp has decided that the particle
size or interest
are 0.5 and 5 microns
and you can see that the grade b at rest
the number of particles match iso 5.
there's your 0.5 and 5 and there's the
number of particles
so you can see gmp has taken a subset of
the iso standard
an important thing to note and a very
contentious issue
is that the 2015 version of the iso
standard 1464-1
does not specify the number of particles
at five mic
icons for iso class 5. there's no number
given
however regulated clean rooms need to
comply with the gmp rules not the iso
rules
so if gmp says they are required to
measure 0.5
and 5 microns so they have to do that so
the fact that the iso standard no longer
mentions the five microns
used to but it doesn't now it does not
mean that the gmp clean room
users do not have to measurement they
still do
okay so we've taken a look at the rules
and regulations for clean rooms
now let's move to the difference between
monitoring and classification
and why these two things are very
different
portable air particle cams are used for
two separate applications
as i said the first is clean room
classification and the second is routine
environmental monitoring
as i said they're very different things
the clean room classification process
is defined very clearly in iso standard
146 44-1
whereas it is the responsibility of the
customer to decide the user designed to
find the routine environmental
monitoring program
specific to their own production process
their product and their clean room
so typically no two routine
environmental monitoring programs are
the same between different sites
now the challenge here is that the
absence of any specific guidance for
routine monitoring
frequently leads clean room users from
what i've seen in my experience
to default to using the same points
for monitoring as they used for
classification
however i can categorically say this is
wrong
each cleanroom user has to take
ownership of their environmental
monitoring program
and they must design the program based
on a risk assessment
of their specific production process
their specific product
and their clean room
our classification focuses on the clean
room itself to ensure
it is performing to the target
cleanliness levels
and the process is very well described
in the iso standard
and typically in the gmp environment
it's carried out every six to 12 months
typically from what i've seen
now this is just an example of clean
room classification it's not meant to
mandate anything specific to you but
in this example here the iso standard
1464-1
tells the user how to calculate the
number of sample locations required for
this clean room
and then tells the user to lay these
sampling locations out
in an evenly distributed grid pattern
across the room
there's no requirements mandated to take
a sample where the product
is at risk of airborne contamination so
in this example following the iso 1464-1
means there are no samples taken in
areas where the product may be at risk
for example the vile table
the filling zone itself and the stopping
or the capping station
now we're switching to monitoring so
we've gone from classification to
monitoring
now it's no regulations specifying
sample locations here there's no hard
and fast rules
gmp tells us that the user must make a
risk assessment
specifically of where the product may be
exposed to airborne contamination in the
manufacturing process
and they must set sampling locations at
these points
for their routine environmental
monitoring programs
so now we go back to the example i used
a moment ago for classification of a
clean room
in this theoretical example the user has
taken a look at their manufacturing
process
and they decided on those locations
where the product may be at risk
and instead of laying out in the grid
format like we did for classification
the monitoring they've laid out their
sampling program
appropriately and you'll notice these
sample locations defined by
the little red dots sorry little yellow
dots there
they're laid out very differently very
different locations to those that were
used for classification
and that's why classification is not
appropriate for routine environmental
monitoring
because there's no consideration made as
to where the product may be at risk
okay so that's the difference between
monitoring and classification
so now let's take a look at the root
cause as to why routine environmental
monitoring
can provide challenging camp so
challenging regards to maintaining data
integrity
this is a typical manual sampling and
counter configuration
process that i've witnessed in clean
rooms
it's a very manual process involving the
collection of thousands of samples
each month at each site using portable
air particle counters
typically there are many manual sop
steps to be followed in
in the routine environmental monitoring
program and the first of these is the
technician firstly has to make sure
they're using the correct version of the
environment of their environmental
monitoring sop
sometimes they change and you need to
make sure you've got the right one and
of course they're paper
based so it's you need to make sure
you're using the correct
sop and then they have to follow the
sampling map
defined in the sop and go to each sample
location marked on a sampling map
and then they have to manually type the
location name for the sample
into the counter via the on-screen
keyboard
and next they have to configure the
counter to sample for the correct amount
of time
and for the correct number of samples
according to the sop
and this may vary for different
locations
having taken the sample the next thing
they do is print the sample results out
from the counter
and handwrite comments onto the print
out and sign it
oh with their name and by signing it
they're making it attributable
attributable to themselves and at the
end of each day
they photocopy all the printouts and
then they manually transcribe
the results from each and every piece of
paper
into an electronic record
remember there's typically hundreds of
these per day and thousands per month
and finally the electronic record is
reviewed by the supervisor
to ensure that all the samples have been
taken and that the data in the
electronic records
match the paper printouts so they have
to manually check
that the electronic record matches the
paper printouts
now you can see this is a very manual
process and with thousands of sample
pieces of paper manual data
transcriptions every month
sadly the opportunity for human error to
creep in and impact the integrity of the
data
is extremely high
now in their 2018 frequently asked
questions paper
the fda highlighted that they were
observing increasing levels of data
integrity issues
and they encouraged the industry to put
in place strategies
to better manage their data integrity
risks in their 2018
guidance on interpreting their 21 cfr
part 11 data integrity rules
the fg fda introduced the acronym alcoa
and they were saying the good electronic
record should be attributable which is
the first a in alcoa
and it should be attributable to the
person taking the sample
and the sample location it should not be
handwritten because sometimes
handwritten can be
misinterpreted or illegible and it
should be made contemporaneously
in other words at the time that the
sample is made rather than created at a
later time
from paper printouts and finally it
should be the original electronic record
and this is probably the key thing the
data that it contains
should be accurate
so you can see we've got an incredibly
manual process here with opportunity for
human error
and at the same time the fda are
encouraging us to
be more rigorous about these programs
make them more robust so
let's take a look at how routine
environment environmental monitoring can
be automated to help improve data
integrity
using the new clarity software
clarity software runs inside the air
particle counter itself so it's not a
separate software piece
and it allows the user to improve
accuracy because you program
the clarity software with your sop and
the sampling map
so the sampling map appears on the
screen of the counter so no more pieces
of paper
and this map creates an interactive
version on screen and
all the technician does is go to each
location and tap on the location on the
screen of the counter
and the counter automatically configures
itself according to the pre-programmed
sop
in the clarity software so
the accuracy is improved because all the
technician has to do now
is tap run sample there's no
configuration or manual data entry
required
and finally accuracy is improved as the
sop version control is now done
inside the counter itself so
administrators log on remotely via web
browser there's no
software required and they configure the
sop and they release it using their
electronic signatures for use by their
technicians
clarity software creates the final
electronic record
inside the counter contemporaneously
there's no more need for paper printouts
or made to manual data transcription
because the record it creates contains
the sop name
and the version number that was used
when the technician did the test
it contains the user electronic
signature which is controlled by
microsoft active directory it contains
the product production batch id the
location name
date and time configuration of the
counter sampling results including the
volume of sample taken
and of course any alert and action
alarms
and the user can manually enter through
the counter screen
using a qwerty keyboard any comments
which are saved with the electronic
record
there is also review and approved
workflow built into clarity which sits
inside the air particle counter
so the clarity software allows the
administrator or the supervisor to log
in
remotely over their corporate network
using
a web browser there's no specialist
software required
the clarity workflow inside the counter
allows the date
sampling to be reviewed and approved for
accuracy
remotely just using this web browser
interface
and then it creates an electronic record
with the electronic signature attached
of the supervisor or the administrator
ready to export straight from the
counter via
usb or wired ethernet or wi-fi
the counter also contains an integrated
audit trail which again helps with
accuracy
any changes to the user id or
anything like that is recorded in there
user logons success and failures log out
sample start sample completion new users
added
changes changes to an sop all of this is
recorded inside the
audit trail in the particle counter
itself
that forms an electronic record which
again can be exported
so that was a quick quick overview of
the clarity software that's inside the
new met 13400 plus
and um i hope you can see how it should
help with uh
improve the data integrity for these
very manual processes
so thank you for listening today i hope
you found it informative and and now
perhaps michelle if we can
go to any questions that you may have in
the chat please
absolutely thank you tony for your
presentation
we'll now start the q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for all right
let's go ahead and get started
okay first question tony thank you for
your presentation
please can you tell me how you can use a
web browser to remotely review and
approve
daily environmental monitoring data
is the counter connected to the internet
well thank you very much for your
question it's a good question
so no the counter is not connected to
the internet what actually happens is
the counter
has its own web server inside the
clarity software
so what you do is you use your web
browser to connect across your company
internal network to the counter
you simply enter the ip address of your
network assigns to the counter
when it connects to your network into
your own web browser navigation bar
and the ip address can be found on the
front screen of the counter
itself
great thank you so much okay let's see
next question how does the counter
assign
electronic signatures to the records
that's a good question thank you and as
i mentioned i think a couple of times in
the presentation the counter
actually uses microsoft active directory
to control
username and password credentials so
when somebody logs on to the counter
using their
active directory credentials the counter
goes across the end corporate network
and verifies that the credentials
they've used
match the active directory on the
network and then assigns the username to
the electronic record
so effectively your microsoft active
directory credentials become the
electronic signature
and it's the same verification process
that happens when you log on to your own
computer when you log on for the day you
go to work you log on using the
microsoft active directory
username and password
thanks tony and let's go ahead and wrap
up with this last question
how do i know if the technician used the
correct sop
version when they did their daily
sampling
yeah again that's so that's the typical
challenge that people face
because these are typically paper based
but now all the sop version control is
done
inside the counter using the clarity
software
the technicians only have access to the
latest version of the sop
on the counter and this is controlled by
the manager or the administrator
who programmed the current sop version
into the counter
and they release it for use using their
electronic signature again using
microsoft active directory
and so you can verify which i think was
the question
which sop version which was used because
the sop
name and version number used is recorded
in every electronic record that the
clarity software
creates
thank you again tony for your time today
and your research
we would also like to thank labrus and
our sponsor
beckman coulter life sciences for
underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and further questions
any questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by tony via the contact
information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
laborers will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event
until next time goodbye